[Music]
I'm the luckiest guy in the world
I got to see the last case of killer
smallpox in the world I was in India
this past year and I may have seen the
last cases of polio in the world there's
nothing that makes you feel more the
blessing and the honor of working in a
program like that than to know that
something that horrible no longer exists
which I'm going to touch so I'm going to
show you some dirty pictures they are
difficult to watch but you should look
at them with optimism because the horror
of these pictures will be matched by the
uplifting quality of knowing that they
no longer exist but first I'm going to
tell you a little bit about my own
journey my background is not exactly the
conventional medical education that you
might expect when I was an intern at San
Francisco I was I heard about a group of
Native Americans who were taken over
Alcatraz Island and a Native American
who wanted to give birth on that island
and no other doctor wanted to go and
help her give birth I went out to
Alcatraz and I lived on the island for
several weeks she gave birth I caught
the baby I got off the island I landed
in San Francisco and all the press
wanted to talk to me because my three
weeks on the island made me an expert in
Indian Affairs I wound up on every
television show someone saw me on
television they called me up and they
asked me if I'd like to be in the movie
and to play a young doctor for a bunch
of rock-and-roll stars who were
travelling in a bus ride from San
Francisco to England I said yes I would
do that so I became the doctor in an
absolutely awful movie called medicine
ball caravan now you know from the 60s
you read around the bus you're off the
bus I was on the bus my wife and I of 37
years joined the bus hour bus ride took
us from San Francisco to London we
switched buses at the big pond we
we then got on two more buses and we
drove through Turkey and Iran and
Afghanistan over the Khyber Pass into
Pakistan like every other young doctor
this is us at the Khyber Pass and that's
our bus we had some difficulty getting
over the Khyber Pass but we wound up in
India and then like everyone else in our
generation we went to live in a
Himalayan monastery this is just like a
residency program for those of you that
are in medical school and we studied
with a wise man our guru neem Karoli
Baba who then told me to get rid of the
dress put on a three-piece suit go join
the United Nations as a diplomat and
work for the World Health Organization
then he made an outrageous prediction
that smallpox would be eradicated and
this was God's gift to humanity because
of the hard work of dedicated scientists
and that prediction came true and this
little girl is Rehema Bono and she was
the last case of killer smallpox in the
world and this document is the
certificate that the global Commission
signed certifying the world to have
Radek ated the first disease in history
the key to eradicating smallpox was
early detection early response I'm going
to ask you to repeat that early
detection early response can you say
that early detection early response
smallpox was the worst disease in
history it killed more people than all
the wars in history in the last century
it killed 500 million people more than
two you're reading about Larry Page
already somebody reads very fast in the
year that Larry Page and Sergey Brin
with whom I have a certain affection
that a new affiliation in the year in
which they were born 2 million people
died of smallpox we declared smallpox
eradicated in 1980 this is the most
important slide that I've ever seen in
public health because it shows you to be
the richest and this
to be kings and queens of the world did
not protect you from dying in smallpox
never can you doubt that we are all in
this together but to see smallpox from
the perspective of a sovereign is the
wrong perspective you should see it from
the perspective of a mother watching her
child develop this disease and standing
by helplessly day one day two day three
day four day five day six your mother
and you're watching your child and on
day six
you see pustules that become hard day
seven they show the classic scars of
smallpox and bill ocation day eight and
Al Gore said earlier that the most
photographed image in the world the most
printed image in the world was that of
the earth but this was in 1974 and as of
that moment this photograph was the
photograph that was the most widely
printed because we printed two billion
copies of this photograph and we took
them hand to hand door-to-door to show
people and asked them if there was
smallpox in their house because that was
our surveillance system we didn't have
Google we didn't have web crawlers we
didn't have computers by day nine you
look at this picture and you're
horrified I look at this picture and I
say thank God because it's clear that
this is only an ordinary case of
smallpox and I know this child will live
and by thirteen day thirteen the lesions
are scabbing his eyelids are swollen but
you know this child has no other
secondary infection and by day twenty
while he will be scarred for life he
will live there are other kinds of
smallpox that are not like that
this is confluent smallpox in which
there isn't a single place on the body
where you could put a finger and not be
covered by lesions flat smallpox which
killed 100 percent of people who got it
and hemorrhagic smallpox the most cruel
of all which had a predict predilection
for pregnant
women I've probably had 50 women die
they all had hemorrhagic smallpox I've
never seen anybody die from it it wasn't
a pregnant woman in 1967 the w-h-o
embarked on what was an outrageous
program to eradicate a disease in that
year there were 34 countries affected
with smallpox by 1970 we were down to 18
countries 1974 we're down to five
countries but in that year smallpox
exploded throughout India and India was
the place where smallpox made its last
stand in 1974 India had a population of
600 million they're 21 linguistic states
in India which is like saying 21
different countries the to 20 million
people on the road at any time in buses
and trains walking 500,000 villages a
hundred and 20 million households and
none of them wanted to report if they
had a case of smallpox in their house
because they thought that smallpox was
the visitation of a deity sheetal amah
the cooling mother and it was wrong to
bring strangers into your house when the
deity was in the house no incentive to
report smallpox wasn't just India that
had smallpox deity smallpox deities were
prevalent all over the world so how we
eradicated smallpox was max vaccinations
wouldn't work you could vaccinate
everybody in India but one year later
there'd be 21 million new babies which
was then the population of Canada it
wouldn't do just to vaccinate everyone
you to find every single case of
smallpox in the world at the same time
and draw a circle of immunity around it
and that's what we did in India alone my
hundred and fifty thousand best friends
and I went door-to-door with that same
picture to every single house in India
we made over 1 billion house calls and
in the process I learned something very
important every time we did a
house-to-house search we had a spike in
the number of reports of smallpox when
we didn't search we had the illusion
that there was no disease
when we did search we had the illusion
that there was more disease a
surveillance system was necessary
because what we needed was early
detection early response so we searched
and we searched and we found every case
of smallpox in India we had a reward we
raised the reward we continue to
increase the reward we had a scorecard
that we wrote on every house and as we
did that the number of reported cases in
the world dropped to zero and in 1980 we
declared the globe free of smallpox it
was the largest campaign in United
Nations history until the Iraq war a
hundred and fifty thousand people from
all over the world doctors of every race
religion culture and nation who fought
side by side brothers and sisters with
each other not against each other in a
common cause to make the world better
but smallpox was the fourth disease that
was intended for eradication we failed
three other times we failed against
malaria yellow fever and yaws but soon
we may see polio eradicated but the key
to eradicating polio is early detection
early response this may be the year we
eradicate polio that will make it the
second disease in history and David
Heyman who's watching this on the
webcast David keep on going work close
we're down to four countries
[Applause]
I feel like Hank Aaron Barry Bonds can
replace me any time let's get another
disease off the list of terrible things
to worry about I was just in India
working on the polio program the polio
surveillance program is four million
people going door to door that is the
surveillance system but we need to have
early detection early response blindness
the same thing the key to this
discovering blindness is doing
epidemiological surveys and finding out
the causes of blindness so you can mount
the correct response the saver
foundation was started by a group of
alumni of the smallpox eradication
program who having climbed the highest
mountain tasted the elixir of the
success of eradicating a disease wanted
to do it again and over the last 27
years save as programs in 15 countries
have given back sight to more than 2
million blind people saver got started
because we wanted to apply these lessons
of surveillance and epidemiology to
something which nobody else was looking
at as a public health issue blindness
which heard afore had been thought of
only as a clinical disease in 1918 1980
Steve Jobs gave me that computer which
is Apple number 12 and it's still in
Kathmandu and it's still working and we
ought to go get it and auction it off
and make more money for Saiva and we
conducted the first Nepal survey ever
done for health and the first nationwide
blindness survey ever done we had
astonishing results instead of finding
out what we thought was the case that
blindness was caused mostly by glaucoma
and trachoma
we were astounded to find out that
blindness was caused
instead by cataract you can't cure or
prevent what you don't know is there in
your Ted packages there's a DVD infinite
vision about dr. V and the Aravind Eye
Hospital I hope that you will take a
look at it Arvind which started as a
save a pride
now the world's largest and best eye
hospital this year that one Hospital
will give back sight to more than
300,000 people and Tamil Nadu
[Applause]
[Music]
representative all terrible things this
might be the worst the key to preventing
or mitigating pandemic bird flu is early
detection and rapid response we will not
have a vaccine or adequate supplies of
an antiviral to combat bird flu if it
occurs in the next three years
w-h-o stages the progress of a pandemic
we are now at stage three on the
pandemic alert stage with just a little
bit of human-to-human transmission but
no human to human to human sustained
transmission the moment w-h-o says we've
moved to category 4 this will not be
like Katrina the world as we know it
will stop there'll be no airplanes
flying would you get in an airplane with
250 people you didn't know coughing and
sneezing when you knew that some of them
might carry a disease that could kill
you for which you had no antivirals or
vaccine I did a study of the top
epidemiologists in the world in October
I asked them these are all flu ologists
and specialists in influenza and I asked
them the questions you'd like to ask
them what do you think the likelihood is
that there'll be a pandemic if it
happens how bad do you think it'll be 15
percent said they thought there'd be a
pandemic within three years but much
worse than that 90 percent said they
thought there'd be a pandemic within
your children or your grandchildren's
lifetime and they thought that if there
was a pandemic a billion people would
get sick as many as a hundred and
sixty-five million people would die
there would be a global recession and
depression as our just-in-time inventory
system and the tight rubber band of
globalization broke and the cost to our
economy of one to three trillion dollars
would be far worse for everyone than
merely
hundred million people dying because so
many more people would lose their job
and their healthcare benefits that the
consequences are almost unthinkable and
it's getting worse because travel is
getting so much better let me show you a
simulation of what a pandemic looks like
so we know what we're talking about
let's assume for example the first case
occurs in South Asia it initially goes
quite slowly you get two or three
discrete locations then there'll be
secondary outbreaks and the disease will
spread from country to country so fast
that you won't know what hit you within
three weeks it will be everywhere in the
world now if we had an undo button and
we could go back and isolate it and grab
it when it first started if we could
find it early and we had early detection
and early response and we could put each
one of those viruses in jail that's the
only way to deal with something like a
pandemic and let me show you why that is
we have a joke this is an epidemic curve
and everyone in medicine I think
ultimately gets to know what it is
but the joke is an epidemiologist likes
to arrive at an epidemic right here and
ride to glory and the downhill curve but
you don't get to do that usually usually
arrive right about here what we really
want is to arrive right here so we can
stop the epidemic but you can't always
do that but there's an organization that
has been able to find a way to learn
when the first cases occur and that is
called gphin it's the global public
health information network and that
simulation that I showed you that you
thought was bird flu that was SARS and
SARS is the pandemic that did not occur
and it didn't occur because gphin found
the epidemic Japan of the pandemic to B
of SARS three months before WH o
actually announced it and
because of that we were able to stop the
SARS pandemic and I think we owe a great
debt of gratitude to gphin and to Ron
st. John who I hope is in the audience
someplace over there who's the founder
of gphin hello Ron
[Applause]
and Ted has flown round here from Ottawa
where gphin is located because not only
did gphin find SARS early but you may
have seen last week that Iran announced
that they had bird flu in Iran but
chiefin found the bird flu in Iran not
February 14th
but last September we need an early
warning system to protect us against the
things that are humanity's worst
nightmare
and so my Ted wish is based on the
common denominator of these experiences
smallpox early detection early response
blindness polio early detection early
response pandemic bird flu early
detection early response it is a litany
it is so obvious that our only way of
dealing with these new diseases is to
find them early and to kill them before
they spread so my Ted wish is for you to
help build a global system an early
warning system to protect us against
humanity's worst nightmares and what I
thought I would call it is early
detection but it should really be called
total early detection
[Laughter]
[Music]
what
but in all seriousness because this idea
is birthed in Ted I would like it to be
a legacy of Ted and I'd like to call it
the international system for total early
disease detection and instead then
becomes our mantra so instead of a
hidden pandemic of bird flu we find it
and immediately contain it instead of a
novel virus caused by bio terror or bio
error or shift or drift we find it and
we contain it instead of industrial
accidents like oil spills or the
catastrophe in Bhopal we find them and
we respond to them instead of famine
hidden until it is too late we detect it
and we respond and instead of a system
which is owned by a government and
hidden in the bowels of government let's
build an early detection system that's
freely available to anyone in the world
in their own language let's make it
transparent non-governmental not owned
by any single country or company housed
in a neutral country with redundant
backup in a different time zone and a
different continent and let's build it
on gphin let's start with gphin let's
increase the websites that they crawl
from twenty thousand to twenty million
let's increase the languages they crawl
from seven to seventy or more let's
build in outbound confirmation messages
using text messages or SMS or instant
messaging to find out from people who
are within 100 meters of the rumor that
you hear if it is in fact valid and
let's add satellite confirmation and
we'll add gap minders amazing graphics
to the front end and we'll grow it as a
moral force in the world finding out
those terrible things before anybody
else knows about them and sending our
response to them
so that next year instead of us meeting
here lamenting how many terrible things
there are in the world we will have
pulled together use the unique skills
and the magic of this community and be
proud that we have done everything we
can to stop pandemics other catastrophes
and change the world beginning right now
[Applause]
[Music]
so an amazing presentation
first of all just so everyone
understands you are saying that by build
it by creating web crawlers looking on
the internet for patterns we could they
can detect something suspicious before
w-h-o before anyone else can see it just
exploit give an example of how that
could possibly be true first of all
you're not mad about the copyright
violation no I love it well you know as
Ron st. John I hope you'll go and meet
him in the dinner afterwards and talk to
him when he started gphin and in 1997
there was an outbreak of bird flu h5n1
it was in Hong Kong and a remarkable
doctor in Hong Kong responded
immediately by slaughtering 11.5 million
chickens and birds and they stopped that
outbreak in its tracks immediate
detection immediate response then a
number of years went by and there were a
lot of rumors about bird flu Ron and his
team in Ottawa began to crawl the web
only crawling twenty thousand different
web sites mostly periodicals and they
read about and heard about a concern of
a lot of children who had high fever and
symptoms of bird flu they reported this
to wh o wh o took a little while taking
action because WH o will only receive a
report from a government because it's
the United Nations but they were able to
point to WH o and let them know that
there was this surprising and
unexplained cluster of illnesses that
look like bird flu that turned out to be
SARS that's how the world found out
about SARS and because of that we were
able to stop SARS now what's really
important is that before there was gphin
a hundred percent of all the world's
reports of bad things whether you're
talking about famine or you're talking
about bird flu or you're talking about
Ebola a hundred percent of all those
reports came from nations the moment
these guys in Ottawa on a budget of 800
thousand dollars a year got cracking 75%
of all the reports in the world came
from gphin 25% of all the reports in the
world came from all the other 180
nations now here's what's really
interesting after they'd been working
for a couple years what do you think
happened to those nations they felt
pretty stupid
so they started sending in their reports
early and now they're reporting
percentages down to 50% because other
nations have started to report so can
you find diseases early by crawling the
web of course you can can you find them
even earlier than gphin does now of
course you can you saw that they found
SARS using their Chinese web crawler a
full six weeks before they found it
using their English web crawler well
they're only crawling in seven languages
these bad viruses really don't have any
intention of showing up first in English
or Spanish or French so yes I want to
take gphin I want to build on it I want
to add all the languages of the world
that we possibly can I want to make this
open to everybody so that the health
officer in Nairobi or in Patna Bihar
will have as much access to it as the
folks in Ottawa or in CDC and I want to
make it part of our culture that there
is a community of people who are
watching out for the worst nightmares of
humanity and that it's accessible to
everyone
[Music]
what if great ideas weren't cherished
what if they carried no importance
[Music]
we're held no value
there is a place where artistic vision
is protected where inspired design ideas
live on to become ultimate driving
machines
[Music]
you